Another relationship that we have to understand is
the one between fabrication cost and our chip area.
Chips are manufactured by taking a silicone disk, called
a wafer, and subjecting it to a number of
steps. Each of these steps sort of prints some
of the aspects of the circuitry that should be
appearing on each processor. And there are a number
of these steps. At the end of these steps,
we take the wafer and we cut it up, and
each one of these small, squarish things is going to be
a chip. So this is a single chip. We take
each chip and we put it in a package. Has pins
on it. So this is what you normally see as
a chip. And then we test these chips. The ones
that check out fine, we can sell. The ones that
don't check out fine, we throw away because they don't work.
It is important to understand that the manufacturing
process up to cutting the chips up is all
the same. The wafer is this. Is about
12 inches in diameter. It cost thousands of dollars
to put it through the manufacturing process, at
which point we hope we get a number of
working chips and very few non-working chips, but
the size of the chip significantly affects the cost.
Again this entire process pretty much has a fixed
cost. If we have more chips here because they are
smaller, we will divide the wafer cost by the number
of many good chips that we get and our chips
will be cheaper. If we have very large chips, we
will get fewer of them when we test them especially
and we will divide this cost with fewer chips to
get the cost. So it seems like the cost of
a single chip is going to be linearly proportional to
its size, but in fact, things are worse than that.